.
dede rénovictions, Émilie Poirir
etet Éric Gendron ont dû
sese trouver un autre logement
àà M Montréal.
- - Lui, il me disait : Moi, c't
ssûr r que le prochain "step",
c'c'est acheter. Lui, il regardt
dedes maisons et moi, je regards
dedes logements à l louer.
- - Comme bien des millénariaux,
ilils rêventnt de devenir
prpropriétaires, mais,
avavec la folie
dudu marché immobilier actuel,
ilils ont décidé de repousser
leleur projet d'achat.
- - Ça fait juste monter,
çaça fait juste monter,
cece n'est pas achetable.
- - Je n'ai pas le goût
dede me retrouver
dadans une surenchère..
- - Avec la hausse des prix,
rerepousser l'accès s à l la pré
esest plus fréquent,
seselon cet économiste.
RIRICARDO TRANJAN, Centre canadn
dede politiques alternatives
- - Le prix des maisons augmente
plplus vite que les salaires,
auaussi beaucoup plus vite que
l'l'inflation, alors l'accèss
àà la a propriété, ça devient
dede plus en plus difficile.
- - Pour une personne âgéee
dede 25 à 3 35 ans, on estime qe
lele nombre d'années de travail
popour économiser une mise
dede fonds de 20 % est passé
dede cinq ans en 1976 à 1 13 ans
enen moyennene au Canada.
DaDans certaines villes comme
VaVancouver, on parle de 26 ans,
àà Tororonto, 21 ans
etet à M Montréal, 10 ans.
MaMais peut-on parler d'inéquité
inintergénérationnelle?
FRFRANÇOIS DES ROSIERS, Dept.
fifin., assur. et imm., ULaval
- - L'inéquité
inintergénérationnelle,
efeffectivement, c'est quelque
chchose qu'on note.
MaMais, ce que je vous dirais,
c'c'est que l'inéquité
inintergénérationnelle n'est pas
éqéquitablement répartie.
- - D'abord parce qu'elle est ps
prprésente dans les grandes
vivilles, ensuite parce que
bebeaucoup de premiers acheteurs
rerecoivent de l'aide
dede leurs parents, ce qui est
lele cas d'Émilie et Éric.
- - Je pense que, si c'était jue
dede moi et de mes économies,
çaça ne serait pas possible.
- - En plus de creuser
leles inégalités, ces retards
d'd'accès s à l la propriété oni
un impact sur le marché locatif.
FRFRANÇOIS DES ROSIERS, Dept.
fifin., assur. et imm., ULaval
- - À l'heure actuelle, ce qu'on
vovoit, c'est que ces gens-là,,
ilils se rejettent sur le marché
lolocatif, demeurent locataires
plplus longtemps et donc, ça fat
unune pression à l la hausse
susur les loyers aussi.
- - Émilie et Éric paient
mamaintenant le double en loyer
dede ce qu'ils payaient
auauparavant. Ce sera donc
plplus difficile d'économiser
popour une maison.
- - C'est sûr quque ça fait peu,
c'c'est sûr r qu'on se dit :
EsEst-ce qu'on est mieux
d'd'attendre cinq ans, mais que,
dadans cinq ans, ça va être e pe